hello there
today we are going to talk about
positional embeddings
you should have heard of them because
wherever you see
a transformer neural network you also
see positional embeddings attached to
them
and because transformers are now really
everywhere in machine learning
irrespectively of the data type you
should have come across positional
embeddings already but what are
positional embeddings
why do we need them in transformers in
the first place and
how do they work well today we are going
to lift the mystery over positional
embeddings
transformers are more and more important
for machine learning and have been
proven to work
very well on any kind of data
especially when there is a lot of it to
pre-train
through self-supervision a big part of
the data that we are interested in
comes in a specific order if we change
this order
the meaning of the input might also
change
the transformer does not process the
input in order sequentially but in
parallel
for each element it combines information
from the other elements through
self-attention but each element does
this aggregation
on its own independently of what the
other elements do or have done yet
because the transformer architecture per
se does not model the order of the input
anywhere
we must encode the order of the input
explicitly
for the transformer to know that one
piece comes after the other
and not in any other permutation this is
where positional embeddings come
in they are sort of an identifier
an obvious hint for the transformer
encoding the whereabouts of
a piece of the input within the sequence
these embeddings are then added to the
initial vector representation of the
input
this addition can be intuitively
understood as
look the initial vector representation
of the word queen
is here in the multi-dimensional space
it is close to king because of word
frequency distribution reasons
king and queen often occur in the same
context
but then we add this positional
embedding identifying the order of
the word hereby we say queen
should move a bit along this dimension
towards this specific part of the space
to cluster
with all the other first tokens in any
other sequence
space and dimension which we do not
really have in this 2d
drawing but you get the idea that by
adding these vectors we move
the initial representations into the
direction of the other first
tokens or the second tokens and so on
at least this is how ms coffee bean
pictures it and you will possibly ask
but how can this little
multi-dimensional shifting help the
transformer
well remember we are working with a
multi-dimensional spurious correlation
identifying beast which is a neural
network
therefore why should these systematic
shifts not be
enough of a hint for it so in short
positional embeddings are
a order or position identifier
added to vectors for the transformers to
know
the order of the sequence these
positional embeddings must fulfill
some requirements first every position
should have the same identifier
irrespectively of the sequence length or
of what exactly the input is
so while the sequence might change the
positional embeddings
stay the same secondly because the
embeddings push the original vectors by
a bit into
let's say the first token club
they should not be too large otherwise
they push the vectors into
very very distinct subspaces
where the positional similarity or
dissimilarity
overtones the semantic similarity
okay then let's see the solution to this
problem as presented by the attention is
all you need paper
introducing the transformer their choice
of positional embeddings is not
the easiest one and is best understood
if you have some knowledge of fourier
analysis
but let's forget about that and explain
it simply
you could think of the sequence as words
coming in one after the other so the
first idea
is to take a non-periodic function and
number your sequence from one to the
total number of tokens you have
but with this recipe we violate the
second requirement
of positional embeddings where we said
that shifts should be
small in other words bounded then let's
look at a function
that is bounded in the values it can
take
like the sine or cosine periodically
returning to
values between 1 and -1 sines and
cosines have the upside that they are
defined
up to infinity so even with enormous
sequence
lengths we would still have something
between -1 and 1 as
elements for our positional embeddings
in comparison to a sigmoid which is
also bounded sines and cosines have a
lot of variability also for
big numbers okay so let's choose a sine
function to model this
but we see that with this periodic
function the same
outcome would repeat for different
positions
let's suppose for a moment that we do
not want that and give our sine
function such a low frequency that even
for our biggest sequence length the
numbers would not repeat
with this we almost have the same
situation as
our linear function because we numbered
our sequence in
order but this time with unique values
between 0
and 1. this is still not optimal because
we remember
our positional embeddings push the input
a bit to create positional
clubs but we also do not want to push by
too much because otherwise
distances between points become
dominated by the position
and not the semantics we also don't want
too little differences between the first
or the second token
because in this case the semantic signal
would
overtone the positional embedding signal
that now contains values that differ
very little between
let's say the first or the second token
so what to do
well if one value in one dimension is
too small of a signal
let's make our intent more obvious by
using all the other dimensions too
for the next dimension we could use a
cosine which would look like this
yet we still have the problem that
embedding values
between one token and the next one do
not differ by much
but if we increase the frequency of the
cosine
the values differ more because the slope
has
increased okay so for this second
dimension let's use a cosine
with increased frequency to create more
differentiated values the second and
first dimension together
are uniquely differentiating tokens one
from another
but now also with values that
differentiate consecutive
tokens more and if we do this for every
dimension
meaning that we alternate between sines
and cosines with
increasing frequency we give enough
information to ensure
that the transformer cannot miss this
order of the sequence
so to recapitulate what we did the last
dimension tells us broadly
where the token is like is it more at
the beginning or more towards the end of
the sequence
but because the values are so continuous
we do not have
enough resolution to say if it is the
first or the second token exactly
then the second to last dimension has
higher frequency
thus higher resolution because we
already know
that we are at the beginning of the
sequence we can pin down
with more accuracy where we are exactly
the next dimension spin down with even
more acuity
where we are in the sequence well
this was the sine and cosine way of
encoding position
but this is not the only way to do it
this
sine and cosine embeddings seem to work
well on text but
what if you have other types of data
like
graphs or images let us know would you
be interested in
relative position representations and or
learned positional embeddings if yes
write us in the comments and i could
convince miss coffee bean to cover this
in one of our very next videos or let us
know in the comments about any other
exotic or not so exotic positional
embeddings
we would like to know about miss coffee
bean why are you poking me
ah thanks for reminding me so we now
have a patreon page
and a coffee page so if you want and
have the means to support
us now you can we would greatly
appreciate it
but if you can't it's fine it does not
change
anything our videos will stay free to
watch for everyone
you